[Applaudissements]
on va mettre le holà sur les jean gaulin
ta réponse première réponse vous me
donnez la question c'est bien sûr toute
l'actu du week end la première réponse
j'adore ses petites fesses
s'il vous plaît jean luc lhemanne doit
vous montrer ce que c'est calculé là
bien sûr ce serait vraiment mais c'est
pas possible non mais c'est un hymne aux
lycéens mais aussi madame a j'adore cet
effet si bas que dit de vous mettiez de
lambeaux nom annonce
valérie blake a dit de vous samedi soir
eva longoria ah oui
s'il vous plaît pas de commenter
non mais oui que dit la france de vos
fesses
j'imagine me fait jeudi jean castex 2
capus kadid denitsa ikonomova propos des
fesses de michou fort
[Applaudissements]
danse avec les stars sur tf1 c'est
l'actrice lucie lucas qui a quitté
l'aventuré sama ça m'a fait beaucoup de
peine
je n'étais vraiment pas bien la
roche-sur-yon et j'étais en train de
manger et ce qui a beaucoup fait parler
ce sont les nombreuses remarques de la
danseuse denitsa sur les fesses de
michou le le jeune youtuber de 20 ans me
shoofey adore et denitsa que j'adore
aussi j'adore denitsa qui est un amour
et des internautes ont dénoncé le
sexisme de ses remarques sur indigné
parce que ces commentaires ne serait
jamais passé c'est un homme il est ce là
une femme on a un petit récap et on en
parlera après c'est vrai que là ça vient
comme tous les vendredis soir danse avec
les stars étaient de retour sur tf1 pour
son septième prime inédite cette semaine
le youtuber michaud s'illustrer dans un
tango argentin sur une chanson de big
flo et oli
même si la prestation fut un succès un
petit commentaire de denitsa ikonomova
désormais jury dans l'émission a
pourtant suscité la polémique moi
j'adore toujours ses petites fesses
évidemment des réseaux n'ont relevé le
côté gênant et sexiste de cette phrase
qui n'était pourtant qu'un petit
compliment et remarques de demsa sur les
fesses de michou me dérange c est l
inverse un homme qui faisait des
remarques sur les fesses d'une femme
qu'il s'en prendrait plein la tête alors
comprenez vous la polémique sur la
phrase de déni de sa dendal ce bon alors
là non alors gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
quoi vos si
oui alors on a les deux mamies là les
allemands parce que tout le monde
s'indigne quand les hommes tiennent ce
genre de propos donc jouer avec mélissa
voilà les en sourdine pour les mecs
c'est extrêmement relookant les gens
s'indigne pour les femmes donc c'est
très bien que ça se passe et la pauvre
elle a le droit
qu'on tente quand on nomme
soir tu as des jolies fesses ça m'a fait
plaisir
on a dit ça cas du tabac alors là c'est
dans la bonne humeur au gala qui lui a
dit ça a donc le sexisme c'est que quand
c'est filmé qua
non non mais c'est ridicule c'est
ridicule c'est là c'est la partie sombre
c'est celle cellule le cancer des
réseaux sociaux ces gens là c'est pas
possible quoi qui ferment leur gueule
c'est incroyable a l'air bien oui non
mais c'est ridicule on peut plus rien
dire c'est vraiment du politiquement
correct grotesque vraiment gilles pardon
mais c'est grotesque j'ai rien dit
encore
on ne peut pas parler comme ça une heure
de grande écoute à la télévision
il arrive à faire bouger le cul pour
décompter à des gens qui vont entendre
ça qu'ils vont banalisée l'expression
pas ci fais pas ça la clé
du sexisme pure et services il
incarne
ici donc on combat cette phrase 6 mais
non mais ce que je crois c'est qu'en
fait alain pour flatter la bien pensante
on se force à trouver des problèmes à
chaque fois c'est si oui là que je
comprends pas comment m'en donnait déjà
un homme c'est un homme une femme c'est
une femme déjà au centre effet de mettre
des infos ce soir
[Rires]
mais kelly alors non mais annonce un
homme ou une femme citée
oui oui
t'as pas tout temps comparé tout
comparer me suis baladé sur twitter j'ai
vu les petites mais les petites fesses
de michou je me suis dit la même chose
on s'est tout dit paraît il a des belles
fêtes on le souligne et tambo actuel ou
non
un problème mais oui comme sur tous les
tons d'être hypocrite mais on a des
oeillères c'est insupportable on fait on
veut que ce sexisme l'a d'abord c'est un
concours de danse dans un concours de
danse on peut avoir du temps tommy on
regarde l'anatomie chaud mais oui on
regarde aussi l'anatomie de sa
partenaire moi je trouve que sa
partenaire à de très jolies fesses comme
il joue il a de très jolis voilà je vois
pas où est le problème enfin moi je veux
pas de ce monde gilou finalement toutes
les remarques sur le corps serait
forcément horrible c'est sur ce site
alors par exemple si je dis pardon que
t'es qu'un beau poster je suis raciste
en plus de tous âges de sexy bah oui ça
non mais l'avocat est capturé les
bienvenus pour en dégoter ces gens sont
moches je
ne
me prends pas les gens pour des
imbéciles et très bien faire la part des
choses entre une vraie remarques
sexistes yeux d'un homme qui use de son
pouvoir sur une femme et là une petite
remarque rigolote et sympathique sur une
jury dans un danger un concours de danse
qui empile mais je ne sais pas encore ce
que c'est le corps alors valérie je vais
vous poser une question très simple si
vous êtes magnifique oui et merci tout
votre corps est sublime merci le cas
dans la rue vous suit et vous dit
mais laissez moi finir j'ai même pensé
s'est même pas posée magali selles dans
la rue tout de suite
soler de confiance
justement vient de donner son avenir
d'évoquer ce qu'ils veulent c'est ce qui
est incomparable ce n'est pas bon quand
incomparable et les gens devant leur
téléviseur ils savent très bien faire la
part des choses en un type qui est
louche qui te suit pour te pour te
parler de ton corps et coutumes cognac
l'abruti et quelqu'un à la télévision
cette remarque anodine et c'est vrai que
les gens devant leur téléviseur
[Rires]
ou la tenue pire sur rtl un oui ben ali
c'était ça vous le dire vous tue maman
je dis régulièrement il est beau de sa
c2 fesses et pc pas à mon gros s'il
cesse t n'importe quoi toi
qu'est ce que voulait dire et à dire que
effectivement à force de voir de sexisme
partout et je suis désolé mais 90% des
femmes sont très contents quand on leur
dit qu'elles ont des mails fumée non
gros
que jamais cette agréable compliment
c'est presque ça aujourd'hui jean je
pouvais lui dire une femme vous êtes
belle vous avez un problème vous avons
dégoté sais quoi je suis une agression
avaient toutes ces conneries m'attend
nous pu rien faire c'est dramatique qui
va se passer dire que l'iphone mais bon
écho comme une fois attendons une femme
dire d'un homme il ay là il un très beau
derrière rennes va s'étaler me roy et
bien donc maintenant tu peux pas dire de
quelqu'un vous avez des données fait
vous libérer la parole et dangereux
mais entre autres est dans la rue faire
tes bonne santé les réactions avant
non mais voilà ça oui ça c'est devenu un
sujet si demain je te vois je te croise
je te digestat des belles fesses ça
c'est différent
c'est aujourd'hui c'est
incohérent et en plus j je sais pas
comment tu supportes la situation ici
parce qu'il faut vous misez si les gens
dont vous vous en foutez dit la même
chose que moi et personne
et vous passez votre temps à dire un
matthieu 10 dont mathieu se trouve
présentement moi dire que j'ai une bonne
chance aux diack même si j'en sais rien
il n'y avait rien tu es tranquille kelly
je ne dis pas qu'elle est très jolie ou
qu'elle a une mémoire ou que l'autre il
a des sambas excuse moi c'est bon
si c'est humiliant donc voilà on est
agressé maintenant et pas agresser on se
moque et 11 mai dans ce marais c'est
juste génial on en veut voilà c'est
cyril dit que j'étais belle feinte je
suis contente a dit plein de fois vous
mais moi ça change je suis gay si je
vous dis du coup vous avez un beau qu
elle est passée comme des mutuelles
machin sexuelle agression sexuelle la
junte à gré c'est ma poule
n'hésite pas à m'agresser
la discussion qu'on a eue non non non
non non non non non mais cette façon là
ce serait vraiment est la france a le
bon c'était
salon c'était une confidence je veux
dire votre phase annoncée renonçant
déconneur sud bateaux venant vraiment
rigolé qui rigole pas
tu fais une confidence humaine sera très
important moi si c'est très bien qu'il
faut pas me faire de mal à l'aise en
flux qu'est-ce que tu en train de dire
que c'est un pourri
confiance en lui c'est vrai quand on
pouvait bon alors c'est sûr qu'il va
rien dire peut-être je dis vous allez me
dire que oui
j'ai déjà tout dit merci oui madame le
problème c'est que quand un homme tient
ce genre de propos rigolo et sympathique
comme tu dit valérie il se fait défoncer
donc pourquoi pas une femme
donc tous aujourd'hui est pris pour du
sexy mais je trouve ça très bien mais
voilà ces rouleaux quand ce camp c'est
une femme qui tient ce genre de
proposition au noble métier droite mais
je vous dis pas la même chose c'est
parce qu'une femme est plus faible canam
et qu'elle peut pas défendre c'est pour
ça que c'est grâce à l'existant mais
d'après lui le douaisis et même pas du
tout
est moins forte de canam se fait
agresser assez sexiste mais non mais dès
qu'un homme a le malheur de dire à une
femme qu'elle est jolie ont le défoncer
une femme dit apte à les battre
chez panisse
existence était spectateur merci merci
oui sans nom à soissons coûtera voulons
un vrai je crois que le débat est clos
voilà merci
une miette à thégra une miette année
c'est la réponse quelle est la question
sa part ingrate et le prime de vendredi
soir sur la stac
une miette à petits grains c'est à dire
gratuit
[Rires]
ça pue
les sapins du prime de la star ac ça
parle du prime de la star ac oui
a dit l'ancien participant sofiane après
coup de ses camarades et leur hypocrisie
exactement qu'a dit sofiane ex star ac à
propos de ses anciens camarades du
château samedi soir tf1 diffusait le
dernier est le premier épisode
d'ailleurs d'une série de trois pointes
pour célébrer les 20 ans de la star ac
la saison une saison 5 du programme
était mise à l'honneur ce samedi c'était
l'occasion pour les téléspectateurs de
se remémorer ces deux saisons qui ont
été remportés par jennifer et magalie
vaé et les anciens candidats avaient
tous la rabbit se retrouver sur le
plateau sauf que sofiane de la saison 4
a poussé un gros coup de gueule pour
dénoncer leur hypocrisie il voulait me
dire cet hymne ce quelle hypocrisie à la
télé partout comme partout comme partout
un petit peu plus ça dépend il y en
avait beaucoup sur l'énergie ou sur le
mag
samedi soir tf1 créé l'événement avec
son prime star academy on s'était dit
rendez vous dans vingt ans
une émission spéciale en trois numéros
ou anciens professeurs et élèves se sont
réunis autour de nikos pour revenir et
commenter les moments les plus forts du
télé crochet et tous ces jeunes familles
1 ce samedi c'était les anciens de la
saison 1 mais par jennifer ça a été
tellement fort et intense et de la
saison 5 par magalie vaé qui était sur
le plateau de la scène musicale
vim
un premier prime qui a convaincu 4,2
millions téléspectateurs mais
apparemment pas sofiane ancien candidat
lui aussi qui a commenté l'émission
depuis son canapé ça pas le mandarin
quand il s'agit de la star ac et puis
parce qu'il ya une miette à thégra ça
fait du contenu ça joue la carte de la
fraternité alors que ça se calcule pas
depuis 20 ans sofiane qui dénonce donc
l'hypocrisie des candidats qui vingt ans
après font semblant d'être amis alors la
télé tel un monde d'hypocrites
[Musique]
alors ça ça sert presqu'à j'ai adoré ce
travail m'a dit merci et bienvenue mais
c'est notre europe ok
c'était la saison et la saison 5 la
saison 4 la prochaine fois ce film sera
habitée bien entendu j'ai beau j'aime
beaucoup sofiane vous qui six mois j'ai
pas compris le coup de gueule de sofiane
parce que c'est donnant donnant cette
histoire en fait eux ils se sont servis
de la star qui a 20 ans voire une
autorité la l'astag se sert d'eux pour
fêter les 20 ans de l'émission en plus
ceux qui ont encore une actualité
musicale ça leur permet d'avoir un peu
de promouvoir beaucoup trop beau c'est
quand même énorme après une sur tf1 et
en plus ce que je comprends pas c'est
que sofiane moi j'ai appelé la
production il sera dans les prime nation
d'astarac main sur moi pour il sera là
oui madame moi aussi j'adore social mais
le problème c'est que là je trouve que
et c'est un peu mauvais de sa part parce
que par exemple si on quitte le collège
par exemple moi j'ai 31 ans j'ai pas
voulu vraiment maintenant le cas
ressemble
j'ai pas vu mes camarades pendant
pendant 15 ans mais un truc m'a bien sûr
qu'on va être pote 1 avant de se revoir
mais ça fait 15 ans qu'on sait pas même
si tu étais pas fan de faire trop
chartier ou aimer mais jamais je vois
pas le rapport en fait c'est chouette
pour eux et je pense pas que c'était des
faux bernard montiel car alors
l'hypocrisie la télé vous ça vous
connaît
il dit aimer oui bien sûr que c'est
hypocrite ça dépend de la cote d'amour
elles dépendent du succès que vous
verrez c'est ça c'est tout c'est vrai
vous avez du succès alors là tout le
monde vous adore retrouve formidable
comme vous en ce moment ça va pas durer
sûrement
j'avais 12 ans permanente
[Rires]
au top et non mais le succès dans toutes
les entreprises
non je suis d'accord il bernard sipié
mais je préfère le débat de bernard
montiel votre débat donc la suite laissé
par les patrons des civils il est
beaucoup mieux je trouve que bernard
montiel a beaucoup plus raisonnables
rien dit encore ou venez dire de la
merde petit coup de gueule parce que
j'en ai marre qu'on qu'on crache tout le
temps sur le monde de la télévision moi
je travaillais à tes besoins depuis 25
ans et j'en ai marre qu'on dise que
c'est que de la merde si t'aime pas la
télévision casse toi
la belle ayem c'est devenu renault non
mais arrêtez de dire que le mondial 90
si le monde dans lequel je travaillais
et des gueux la
télévision ça fait 25 ans que oui il ya
des hypocrites que oui j'en ai un mais
ya aussi des gens super il ya aussi les
enjeux non merci je sais qu'il adore
alors non je suis d'accord qu'il ya des
gens très bien été excuse moi ils sont
comme les incultes ou ce et renforcer
notre notoriété ont tellement qu'on
t'aime plus on te dit des hommes des
becques talent de tourner ce que moi
unanime et en plus à la télé il ya un
truc qui est quand même énorme c'est que
je suis le courage c'est parce qu'il est
tout petit match à le dire en face
qu'ils pensent et gérer le feront ils
ont tellement peur de prendre un tour
plus que des deux frangins vais te le
dire mais moi
je vais me suis dit c'est ouais t'as vu
mais j'en ai mal à l'argentine les
services quand même
mais dans les grandes boîtes qu'on y
aille
ménard était naïve de leurs moniteurs en
ce livre elle valérie moi quand j'ai
arrêté l'émission là pendant pendant un
an
j'avais zéro sms et à partir du monde et
moi qui tape la chimérique par des gens
portant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur des émissions sur des choses sur des
preuves et tout ça comme par hasard le
carnet de déjeuner c'est ses rangs
benita des habitations sur une tête bien
qu'ils trouvent forcément très gentil
batellerie négociations les trésors
oubliés valérie vous verrez comment
s'est arrêté j'ai travaillé moi au cully
vd o velho et
du tout et où je
vais causer des chaussettes en cuir est
il a raison il m'a collé je venais des
chaussettes en cuir jean luc rigaut ça
sert à quoi c'est une idée à la con mais
je peux vous dire que j'avais jamais
prospéré ah oui ça marchait très bien
c'est vrai bon train dans les
chaussettes en cui cae
s'est réveillée magnette
les choses
et jean luc hees tôt pense à moi je
pense qu'ils sont sincères je crois
qu'il ya un truc qui se passe c'est que
au bout d'un moment si tu as partagé des
trucs intense avec des tubes comme gaby
exactement mois avec le temps je me
souviens que des bonnes choses mais
c'est ça c'est ça et je pense que la
mémoire et c'est quand même dans une
histoire d'amour mais c'est comme quand
damon stage il une émission de télé
quand la roue hors dia c'était peut-être
moins bien que ce que je pensais le
cerveau fait que dassa coutu garde que
les meilleurs moments et ils ont vécu
des moments intenses je pense qu'ils se
sont frites et pendant la fiac mais je
pense qu'ils s'étaient sentis mais sur
la télé tu trouves que dire ce que dit
benjamin cantat plus d'appels tout ça
c'est difficile on fait des métiers
publics et on a besoin des autres pour
travailler donc évidemment que s'il
était un petit peu moins dans le mien on
t'appelle - ça c'est évidemment je suis
d'accord aussi avec valérie cd schéma
qui se produisent dans tous les cas
c'est moins violent
c'est moi marc darmon tiennent à nous
c'est très bon mois 37 ans c'est pas une
compétition d'année télévision moi je te
dire c'est un moment quand j'ai été viré
je peux te dire personne ne m'a jamais
avoué qu est ce que tu
je marchais dans la rue ce que j attends
je peux faire un baiser les gens qui
n'ont rien eu droit quand j'allais des
chaussettes en clair le fabricant vient
me chercher à léry tu parlais de
télévision valérie meetic pas la
télévision c'est mon métier je laime
c'est pour ça que j'y suis je te dise a
pas de volonté je suis à chelsea au sol
au jeu le compte sur personne donc je ne
suis pas déçu mais je me perds tu te
barres de la télé quand tu es plus dans
les lumières a battu n'existe plus c'est
tout et c'est pas grave il faut le
savoir je veux quelqu'un qui est
d'accord avec bernard montiel d'accord
avec dedans alors oui au reer vous
pouvez donc la mairie ça n'a rien à voir
avec le doute vous en troquant vous je
prends la télévision depuis l'entrée de
tous les vices chez l'être humain et la
notoriété de pouvoir l'argent le sexe le
succès aux divisions sacré
[Applaudissements]
c'est sa semaine jusqu'à samedi minuit
[Rires]
voilà assez fort
dégueulasse quand tu as tout m'intéresse
à toi et qu'en tu as rien t'es une merde
est la vérité arrêtez géraldy donc non
mais vous voulez pas m'entendre parler
mais quand même j'allais dire tu veux
cela j'allais dire la même chose que
valérie je reçois du tout la politique
vous pensez que c'est l'île aux enfants
savoir si m mais alors on parle on parle
des métiers où elle serait pas les
rédacteurs avocats les médecins qui les
six semaines mais vous pas non mais vous
parlez des travaux quai des chercheurs
ça rien à voir c'est le même série mais
le showbiz mais c'est un monde de
requins il faut le dire valérie c'est un
monde de requins ou les ambitions ou les
ambitions sont des culs bien sûr il ya
très peu de glace où il ya très peu
retardé et donc on est frères à tous
mais ça c'est comme ça on est prêt à
tout pour piquer la place de l'autre
c'est moi qui l'ait qui dresse héritage
et c'est malin ouais c'est quoi son
caractère huawei a est très gentille et
ça va toujours pas mieux et
puis j'adore eh ben on va regarder
hoyaux pologne très bien merci au revoir
ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs car
s'il vous plaît oui car
j'ai été convaincu par bernard montiel
car cette acquisition pose impression
est ce que c'est un monde d'hypocrites
comme partout ailleurs sa question et
ben voilà on pose la question on aura la
réponse devra l'instant je fais mes
émissions
mais c'est vrai mais benhaim proches
walhalla moi j'aime bien là dessus je
suis pas là notre vie et continuer sur
mon avis j'avais un réseau suivre la
note mais 95% quand même et ça va mais
si vous voulez avoir un prénom
je reste comme ça